hosting a good party is all about good  preparation good snacks good drinks good  choose but even with good planning  Huttese can still go fishing so make  sure you register your party at good  one.org not in zid the good one website  has heaps attempts for making sure your  feet goes off without a hitch and by  registering police fire and noise  control know who to get in touch with if  there's a problem on the night simply  into the details of your party the local  police will call for a quick chat about  your plans and then have a great time  and if things do start to get a bit  hairy so whether you're a student parent  sports club or AA be a great host  register your party and make sure you  have a good one North Kent free it's now  your turn to have a good one with a  batch book jam-packed full of free stuff  and discounts for the first 50 parties  registered in the Waimakariri  [Music]